possible active shooter several people
saw a couple of Mayday chaos erupted as
shots were fired in Monroe Park Tuesday
afternoon we have all
shootings in Monroe Park the area was
filled with families celebrating
Huguenot High School graduates with all
graduates of the class of 2023 please
stand together
who left from the Altria theater
directly across the street just moments
earlier this is their graduation day
the question that comes in my mind right
now is
is nothing sacred any longer it is
probably the worst thing
that I've seen in my life Keisha Allen
was looking for her goddaughter who had
just graduated when the shooting started
it was just total chaos